[Musique]
c'est dans les locaux du parc national à
la plaine des palmistes que se sont
retrouvés les différents acteurs du plan
papam plantes à parfum aromatiques et
médicinales ce mercredi 4 septembre dans
le cadre du projet agri pays 2030 le
département a mis en place ce plan papam
qui vise à poser une stratégie claire et
ambitieuse d'accompagnement du
développement de la filière une activité
qui peut offrir de belles perspectives
tant sur le plan pharmaceutique sur
blanc également du bien-être des parfums
donc il ya un véritablement une source
de richesse à travers ses plans c'est
d'un développement de niche que nous
souhaitons proposer et encourager en
direction du monde de l'aider papam mais
pour autant il faut que nous puissions
aussi récupérer toute la plus value qui
peut être retiré de cette production
agricole la production de papa me
présentant vrai potentiel pour le
développement de l'île pour la mise en
valeur de friches et pour la
conservation de l'environnement
alors quand on veut valoriser les
plantes médicinales
il y à une phase bien sûr de culture
mais aussi ensuite de transformation et
dans cette transformation c'est là où se
fait la plus value la plus importante
donc la présentation par exemple d'un
extraits de plantes ou de d'une plante
qui est dosé qui a été contrôlée
qui a été vérifié et donc c'est très
important que cette transformation se
fasse à l'île de la réunion
bien sûr pour l'emploi mais aussi pour
le retour sur l'investissement que les
agriculteurs que les producteurs ont mis
dans les plantes médicinales
la journée s'est poursuivie par une
visite de l'atelier de transformation
avait mu papam des plans de transformer
de façon industrielle et scientifique
c'est un choix de vie c'est aussi
reconnaître notre patrimoine
reconnaissent que grand-mère grand-père
et arrière-grand-père est grand mais à
la rue l'a transmis à nous ça veut dire
eban la vie de demain n'est pas obligé
de prendre quelque chose chimiques
on peut joie de vivre avec les plantes
réunionnaise puis c'est à saint pierre
que s'est achevée la matinée marc
ayrault séverin productrice et
présidente de la cave coopérative les
huiles essentielles de bourbon qui se
bat depuis des années pour que cette
filière atteignent l'excellence avant on
avait un petit bobo n'allait pas chez
médecins nos parents moi mais mes
parents les chevaliers le boulot avec
alcool non il était grippé donné un
groupe géranium
nous on avait mal au vent même peut-être
lui donner à nous il faisait à babu que
le tombé il prenait un peu de pâte poule
ils tracent des cinq métiers en kata
place sur notre blé yeux et le géranium
très bon cicatrisant n'avait gens
viennent à sable de toute façon le
chimique le chimique toute personne ne
veut plus parler en train de parler
d'une fuite à travers ce plan papam le
département vise la création de
richesses d'emplois et surtout de
bien-être
[Musique]